跟你说啊，
优柔寡断的女的到最后是没有好下场的啊，
优柔寡断被别人推着往前走，
被别人推着生孩子的女的没有一个好下场的啊，
我看到你铁说欺骗了，
我想让你帮我梳理一下，
就是我这个原生家庭，
他这个挺多爸爸的，
现在是第二段婚姻，
这段婚姻因为男方那个，
然后我那会儿也年轻，
我就跟他离婚了，
我今年35岁了，
没什么学历，
就是一个打工的，
家里也是农村的，
然后男方是比我小三岁，
也是农村的，
但是我们这边的习俗就是你近亲之后就是准备结婚了嘛，
不是，
然后彩礼是八万六，
有三亲，
还有2万块钱，
改口钱，
二月份那会儿定的亲，
我在长沙在上班，
后来我就辞职回来了，
在家里装修，
我们俩第一次爆发的那个吵架，
就是因为他装修，
有些东西需要手机买，
我就想用他的手机买，
他就不想给我看他手机，
就想告诉我密码，
当时我就说如果你手机没有什么别的，
我不能看了，
我只是买东西，
你有什么不能告诉我的，
当时都吵架了，
挺委屈的，
我就哭了，
我都走了，
然后他妈的意思就是说他是独生子，
被宠惯了，
然后就是说你理解一下他，
包容一下他，
比他大3岁了。
第二次我觉得他这个人有问题的是郭薇姐，
他上我们家来送东西了，
然后他就走了，
10天没有联系我他妈说她不爱说话，
我就说那你最好上午下班你告诉我一声对吧，
你不是已经给我定亲了吗？
咱俩是准。
没结婚的你是怎么想的，
你不跟我说话，
他说我也不知道我怎么想的，
我当时就觉得是个人，
你这是个什么性格，
我已经发了个朋友圈，
他妈应该是看到的，
然后就找我，
就这子说我们两个就是沟通不良，
他儿子就是随他爸，
不爱说话，
你们俩这样不行，
咱们还是两家人处理一下，
他妈的思想就是我们俩近亲了，
近亲第二天这边有习俗，
就是上男方家住嘛，
他就想让我跟他儿子住一起，
他意思就是说我已经结过婚了，
不应该在意这种事儿，
但是我觉得你虽然说结婚了，
但是没有取结婚证，
我不喜欢这种这种样子，
我就说去取结婚证，
然后去结婚证当天正好拍婚纱照，
我当时就是挺不高兴的，
我以为他是上夜班累了，
我能产生这个情绪的问题，
我他妈就一直在问我们两个怎么不回去，
我说我上我姐她家拿就息了，
我和他可能累了，
先在回家了，
他妈就告诉我说我离过婚，
这个事儿他没告诉他儿子，
因为我这边介绍人是我姐夫，
他那边介绍人是他的嫂子，
我说当时都已经告诉过你们，
你不告诉你儿子，
那是你的问题，
但是你这个事你怎么能瞒着呢？
我就说如果不行的话就退掉，
我跟我爸也说了，
说不行就退婚，
我爸说你都取结婚证了，
你不能退，
你得跟他等我想处再看，
后来就结婚了，
我们领证到现在4个月，
然后结婚2个月，
他并没有跟我合房，
然后他跟他妈说，
说我不让他碰，
他他妈跟我姐夫打电话就是这么告诉他，
说我借钱娶老婆花了十十多万块钱，
你们家闺女还不让我们儿子碰，
你这是教教我的。
我当时我就。
就火大了，
我说我不让你碰了吗？
你怎么跟你妈撒谎呢？
我是先找他妈，
他妈都没跟我说，
我是想让他妈回来说一下这个事儿，
因为我俩结婚之后一直没有就是产生关系，
然后中间有一次我们俩也是吵架，
因为他考科目三老是过不了，
他就七八天不搭理我，
我也不吃我做的饭，
我就寻思你这个东西，
你这个人是咋回事，
你不搭理我，
中间台上别的屋睡的，
我说这样不行，
我就去找他妈，
找他妈说他妈当时没说，
但他后边他跟我姐夫说的，
我就觉得你这个冤枉，
这事不行，
我就跟我爸妈他们接下来说这个事儿，
他就说是我不同意，
我说你这个就是在撒谎，
然后他妈就说你俩这日子到底能不能过，
我就拿东西就走了，
我说我就说你要是寻思退多少，
你说个数，
该退你退你，
你要是说狮子大张口，
那你就是起诉去吧。
可是我回来待一天之后，
他当天他嫂子没去，
待一天之后，
他嫂子给我打电话，
说了之前是有误会的，
解释清楚就好了，
然后这天他嫂子还有他妈他们，
再加上他就来说把我姐夫给弄完了，
就是说这男的啊，
跟你领了结婚证，
也办了婚礼，
走完了程序，
但这男的自始至终都没有想过要亲近你，
也没有任何主动亲近你的这个动作，
是吗？
是的，
有两天晚上他说他想跟我亲近了，
但是我没有感觉出来了，
他只是拥抱了我，
之后他又翻过身去睡觉去了，
后来他就又出去看电视，
他说我让我出去看电视，
但是他每天他下夜班，
他都2点多钟才回来嘛，
他都是。
完了看电视看过，
我玩完游戏之后，
他就上楼睡觉了，
那他是没有谈过对象，
没有过亲密行为的经验吗？
不是，
我那天问过他，
他说他谈过对象，
也跟人家有过亲密接触，
我说你要是是个处男是吧，
你没有这经历我还能理解，
你不是没有这经验，
再说你不是说一天两天，
你两个月，
你不能说中间有这两回，
他说我一说那话他都没有兴致了，
我说你这都是借口啊，
现在的情况就是我爸还有我姐夫都是让我再给他的机会，
那我再跟着给我试试，
但是他妈一开始就想让我们，
想让我赶紧要孩子，
但是我在在结婚之后，
我才了解他们家的经济状况，
就是他爸他妈打工的，
他也是打工的，
房贷是有12年的，
每个月要还2300块钱，
他买车的时候，
我不知道，
他买车没写他儿子的名，
是写的妈的名，
车贷是多少我不知道，
然后你看他们三口人都是劳动力，
他结婚竟然需要借钱，
他那么跟我姐夫说，
他说借十了万，
具体是说的真话假，
他不知道，
他那个首付是9万块钱，
负债是35万，
那你说三口人买房子都花了9万块钱，
然后装修那种花了6万来块钱，
我的彩礼一共10万块钱，
他买金子也就12万块钱，
三口人还要负债，
那你们家这个东西，
他挣钱的这个地方就不对，
他们仨又没有说得过什么大疾病，
他有些地方有好多坑，
我就说如果我跟他去再继续跟他过的话，
我爸的意思就是说他爸不喝酒的话，
他手哆嗦，
他爸就有这个毛病，
但具体是。
毛病我也不知道，
我让他去这他爸检查，
他也不去，
然后这个男生呢，
他没有，
就是一技之长，
就是打工的，
我那会儿不让他干这个工作，
上夜班是在一个那个烧烤店，
一个月3000块钱，
我说那你也养不了家呀，
他不听我的，
那是在这次吵完架的时候，
他辞职了，
弄快递去，
我就觉得你这种情况能生孩子吗？
你生完孩子之后，
我自己打工挣一点钱都得贴补他们家了，
到最后我健康也没有了，
我的钱也没有了，
丈夫也不怎么关心我，
就是前面那段婚姻有孩子吗？
没有，
现在就是说他们家是三个劳动力，
他是独子啊，
目前是欠账的状态是吧，
就是总共欠多少账，
你有捋一捋吗？
没告诉我啊，
车子在妈妈名下，
房子在男方的名下，
对，
然后你俩从领结婚证，
办婚礼，
从相亲算到现在，
认识多久了，
半年8个月了，
然8个月就没有发生过正常的夫妻关系，
对我感觉这个问题挺明显的，
因为男生这种情况的话，
他就这么几个原因嘛，
要么他本身身体有问题，
要么他心理有问题，
要么他取向不是女性，
我现在都不敢说取向有问题，
我觉得取向有问题可能对很多人来说的话，
听起来挺刺耳的啊，
他不是有问题，
就是说取向他不是异性，
他可能取向是同性啊，
要么呢，
他就不喜欢你，
他对你不感兴趣，
这四点的话，
无论哪一点，
咱这日子都过不下去。
无论哪一点咱都没法说，
生孩子啊什么的，
都害了孩子，
我也是这么想的，
但是我妈和我姐夫就是说，
我已经35了，
你还能找什么样子的，
当时是我自己太优柔寡断，
我如果是你，
我35岁了啊，
我就宁可找那个说他也离的，
甚至说他有孩子，
这孩子跟着前妻过的，
但我要找一个，
最起码他对我有兴趣吧，
想睡我吧，
是不是？
就你这情况，
就是他对你没兴趣，
他不想睡你，
其次的话，
他家里条件还不是很好，
还欠了那么多账，
你自己琢磨一下，
如果我啊，
我是你，
我35岁了，
我真的我宁可找那种说他也离了，
有孩子，
但孩子跟前妻过，
不跟他过，
你自己琢磨琢磨啊，
我就是觉得我不能跟他过，
就是我现在反怕不了我爸了，
害怕我爸生气，
我跟你说啊，
优柔寡断的女的到最后是没有好下场的啊，
优柔寡断被别人推着往前走，
被别人推着生孩子的女的，
没有一个好下场的啊，
我就是害怕跟他有孩子，
所以我就一直都是说，
我一开始想现在做错事，
看看时间长了看着怎么样，
反正我的意见摆在这里了，
我昨天也讲过这个话题，
优柔寡断的女的，
你们在精神上一定要杀死自己，
精神上把自己那种优柔寡断的性格，
那个人格给他勒死，
就一定要杀伐决断，
就一定要想明白利弊，
就一定要为自己的决策买单啊，
就这样。
啊，
拜拜啊，
也有朋友说杀伐决断的女性是不会来连麦的，
嗯，
你说这个也有道理啊，
某种程度上的话，
就龙妃姐姐挣的这个钱也更多的是一些优柔寡断的，
前怕狼后怕虎的，
就是琢磨不明白的，
算不明白账的才会来问我，
你说的也有道理啊，
但是我真的，
我每次给的意见，
呃，
某种程度上的话，
都是一种叫什么强者思维，
我给的意见都是强者思维，
就是你一定要把你自己当成一个强者，
当成一个主体，
你才是这个世界的主角，
你才是你世界里面的一个主宰。
记得点赞关注哦。